welcome back one of our favorite events
is back dress for success southern
nevada's
shop for success event it's happening
tomorrow and here to tell us more is
norma in triago
the executive director welcome norma
great to have you back on the show for
someone
that is not familiar tell us what dress
for success is all about
yes the mission of dress for success is
to empower women and we do that in
various ways we
uh empower women to be financially
independent by providing them with
professional work attire but also giving
them a network of support and all the
career development tools that they need
not only to be successful in work but in
life
and clearly today more than ever with
the economic consequences of the
pandemic for women that is critical
you guys you're doing amazing things
let's talk about tomorrow so what
is shop for success it's a huge event
it's happening tomorrow
yes shop for success is our excess
inventory sale we do them throughout the
year
and this is a time where you can shop
for success shop for good
get amazing designer fines bargain buyer
prices
and help uh us all those proceeds will
go back to funneling to our program
to help women in need um we're going to
have an amazing time tomorrow we have a
dj we'll have food trucks
you can shop to your little hearts
desire from 9 00 a.m
to 3 p.m at our um warehouse unit 29 so
it's 3 400. those are in
west desert inn so come by swing by and
and
shock to your heart's content and make
uh impact in our community and i was
looking
those i saw some designer items up there
do you guys have some really cool items
up there
and you're not it's not per item doesn't
it you buy a bag in advance and you fill
your bag is that how it works
right so we have a different so you can
get our
um fines where you can shop and find
amazing items
and these are more our standard items
maybe like express
and you can fill a bag for 35 dollars
with all types of clothing i don't know
where you can do that
uh shoes for ten dollars a pair for 15.
and then if you won our designer they're
discounted 85
wow dress okay
a vera wang dress for 30 dollars
this is unbelievable and it's open to
everyone tomorrow we appreciate it so
much thank you
norma for joining us for more
information visit dress4success
southernnevada.org they've got all the
information thank you norma
rocky over to you